he just laser locked and he was like
because he really wanted to talk about
it he said I've been dreaming of this
shot for 15 years of this sequence and
finally I had a chance to do it well
remember the one where he runs sideways
around the tallest building in the world
this is just another day at work
Michael's well so how did it come to
pass and he goes okay okay so I go to
the safety guy I tell him this is what
I'm going to do
so I'm going to attach myself you know
to a cable and I'm going to run I'm
going to run around the outside of the
building about 1500 feet up or whatever
it was
safety guy
says you can't do that
because that's too dangerous and I'm
like uh-huh uh-huh and he goes
so I get another safety guy
[Laughter]
he works hard for the money you guys
[Applause]